you know the clip that's driving me nuts
Taylor Swift saying when I was on
Saturday Night Live and I got to host
and I don't know she was a kid she was
like 19 years old she goes no one came
to me and gave me any advice that's a
problem like people think you're
supposed to know what to do when you're
hosting Saturday Night Live in a way
it's a a tremendous task insane it is
that is here's what's even crazier I
worked at that show for 12 and 1/2 years
and then I think about 3 years after I
left I went back and hosted for the
first time and if you asked me what it
was like to host I would tell you today
and I worked there longer than almost
anybody I was like Howard no one tells
you anything like even I who had worked
there couldn't believe how it works and
I retroactively felt so guilty about how
I had treated hosts for my time there
and let me make clear I was always very
polite to hosts I I always wanted them
to score if they won I feel like we won
but you know a host sometimes would say
to me I don't understand what I'm doing
this sketch
and in my head what I wanted to say is
just [__] do it right like just do it
we don't have time for nonsense yes we
wrote it just do it and then when I
hosted there were a few times where I
realized what I was thinking was I don't
understand what I'm supposed to do in
this catch know and also Taylor Swift
and it really speaks to what a force of
nature she is and the depths of her
talent but here's a 19-year-old who
again nobody is really helping out
nobody gave her a manual of how to do
that show and yet she came to us and
said I wrote a song for the opening
monologue and I remember saying oh God
that's great and she said can I play it
for you and so we brought Taylor into
Lauren's office and it was maybe me and
Lauren and one other person and Howard
she sings this song which
is not only you know a beautiful song uh
by a beautiful singer it's a perfect SNL
Monologue fully formed and it was I
can't to this day I've sort of Never Had
A Moment Like That where someone brings
you a fully uh gift wrapped present and
it's exactly uh what you needed it to be
so yeah can you imagine I mean having
the balls to walk into Lauren Michaels
office in your office and you guys are
all comfortable you know each other and
this and that and standing there
vulnerable with a guitar the thing I
should have done is when she finished I
should have said now Taylor Just For You
I want to look at you and read what we
had written for you just so you know how
much [__] worse it was like not only
is your song great but you can't even
begin to imagine how shitty what we were
doing for you is compared to how great
what you did for yourself
is